could you imagine
you go into politics you suffer the
slings and arrows all of the attacks
people make on you you forego in in many
cases making better money elsewhere
there I don't know about Kamala Harris
but there are plenty of politicians who
could make way more money in the private
sector than they do in government I'm
not saying she doesn't make a good
salary as a VP or a senator but she
could she could probably make more money
in the private sector you you get to
spend more time with your family when
you're not in government you go through
all of the this the indignities that go
along with holding office for what for
no purpose whatsoever just to be there
just to be the vice president Kamala
Harris doesn't want to do anything in
office she has no agenda whatsoever
she's a completely empty suit not a
whole lot going on I think between the
ears certainly not a whole lot going on
between the shoulders in terms of her
heart in terms of what stirs her and
nothing at all kind of like Joe Biden
she just wants to be the vice president
probably ultimately to be the president
could you possibly imagine